so many people are excited about this
friends reunion you
just shot it yeah what can you tell us
everybody wants to know and there's just
been this veil of secrecy about the
whole thing but i thought
i know lisa i've known her for a long
time if i get her here she'll tell me
everything
i'll tell you everything i'm allowed to
say okay
do you really get a did you really get a
memo of what you're allowed to say
here's here's what i can say okay um
key phrase that we're allowed to say
okay according to warner media or hbo
max
joined by special guests we will all the
cast
um we all shoot it's good i like it i
like it so far
and the fact that you made a little bit
of an error there adds excitement to it
like this is really happening it's real
and there's pressure
yeah okay okay joined by special guests
we all the cast return to the original
soundstage stage 24 on the warner
brothers studio lot
for an unscripted reunion special in
celebration
of the show so
isn't that exciting that's what you're
allowed to say
you know to tempt people yeah sure
well man so i think that whoever wrote
that knows showmanship
they know that's actually it's it's kind
of dangerous
yeah the way it's phrased it could cause
a stampede
also stage 24 yeah
like everyone knows no you did not go
back to stage 24.
for friends come on you know i
we're wrapping things up and we're
obviously not at warner brothers right
now but i we were there for
you know almost we were there for 10
years a decade at
warner brothers and i constantly saw
uh trams with tourists go through warner
brothers
and people were always wanting to see
the friends fountain
the iconic friends fountain yeah and
you'd hear them go by like where's the
friends fountain
and sometimes they'd come they'd like
drive by me and the tour guide would say
and that's conan o'brien and they'd be
like
where's the friends about
i it like i'm a person um did you guys
you can tell me this did you reenact the
iconic you know
opening where you guys were all
frolicking in the fountain no
but i
we're at the fountain and there's
footage that i've never seen before
that i was really excited about
of course so i mean if you do like the
founder interested
we did that then yes that would be kind
of
thrilling and you'll see and what i like
is that it sounds like you're going to
look at a lot of footage that people
haven't seen before and you guys will
take us to that moment or look at
footage that we haven't seen before
well and that is like clips from the
show that some of us
still never saw well that's the other
thing is you never watched
a lot of the shows i shouldn't say that
you never watched all of friends
right right because at first yes we all
got together we watched every episode
but
you know like uh the last few years and
i had a child and
look honestly it wasn't like i'm not
interested and who
cares it was more i have to be just
honest
i'm so self-conscious of okay everybody
shh
i'm on tv now you know i can't
do i have no problem doing that well
yes gather round i'm on television
kids quiet and we begin
daddy i'm bleeding quiet bleed and we'll
take her to the hospital later
you can do your homework later
you can take the sats another day you're
watching me now